so it seems like everybody who comes to
LA from somewhere else has that quote
you know arriving in LA story tell
Shores Tennyson how long ago was it and
what did you take away from it what was
the world well okay I don't know if it's
a moral exactly um so okay I got out
here I didn't know anybody in the
industry and my background was in
theater and I had lots of stagecraft
experience and I kind of figured I was
gonna be able to get a job doing
lighting or something except for one
person who I did know who I'd went to
college with and his girlfriend was
working at a film finance office in
Beverly Hills and he asked me if I
wanted and I'm like of course absolutely
it's a chance to work in the industry
I'll learn things I didn't know and I
started making phone calls for investors
at this little very expensive office
which course legitimized it in my eyes
which is exactly what it was supposed to
do and then as soon as I closed a deal I
got fired so they would have to pay my
commission there was a little thing in
the contract and I was you know I was
young I didn't know any better I didn't
know to call a lawyer or anything like
that and I spent my first holiday here
homeless eating once every two days like
just crashed right into Los Angeles
headfirst into the worst parts of the
industry and uh and and um a couple
months later I saw an ad in variety you
know looking for young professionally
minded upwardly mobile you know what I'm
saying whatever kids to come in and make
phone calls and I figured well and I
have sworn off at that point I'm never
going to get involved in the business
side of film no way I'm gonna find
someone to do my stage craft but I got
hungry and I said I'm gonna get myself
two weeks and go in and do this and then
I'll find something else and that's how
I met the person who taught me basically
everything I know about sales everything
I know about film finance introduced me
to end up working on a show with basil
poledouris which was awesome who is the
composer if you don't know a Robocop and
conan the barbarian and
and and and the hunt for red october
he's a legend in the music side of film
and a bunch of other cool people as well
and and by and by I wound up helping to
build and found unified pictures with
those people so it turned out to be a
really good thing but you know as far as
the lesson of getting scammed you know
what immediate I uh I I got it I got
cynical pretty quick about the film
industry in the business of it and the
article i posted on film courage was
kind of how i learned to let that
cynicism go so i became shall we say
wisely open by and by about my
interactions with Hollywood
you